how are you Bob costis I'm great rich
after one of the most enjoyable weeks of
my entire life
I went up to Cooperstown early I went up
a week ago Saturday I took my kids with
me then family began to trickle in
middle of the week by the time we got to
Saturday's ceremonies there were 50 or
60 people extended family and friends
there plus countless people who were my
baseball acquaintances and friends the
whole atmosphere of it the whole feel of
it was one of the great experiences of
my life it really was it was the first
time you ever went to Cooperstown Bob
first time ever went to Cooperstown was
1974 I was a student at Syracuse and
whitey Ford and Mickey Mantle got in the
same year and so a classmate of mine and
I drove the two of us drove about an
hour and a half from Syracuse to
Cooperstown and there was a restaurant
owner in Syracuse who somehow was a good
friend of Mickey's and so he snuck me
into the library where no members of the
media were supposed to be and who would
have recognized me as a member of the
media anyway because was working on the
college station at Circus and he
introduced me to both Madelyn Ford and
kind of vouched for me and I interviewed
Mickey Mantle and whitey Ford on the day
that they were inducted into the Hall of
Fame so that was my first trip 1970 what
if you told that new house school
student that one day you'd be in the
same museum enshrined with those guys I
would have thought that you had lost
your mind my objective was to become a
sportscaster just like yours was I'm
sure at the same age to become a
sportscaster to become good at it to
become good enough to make a living at
it and I hope to be involved in baseball
but at that time by the way the
broadcaster's wing at the Baseball Hall
of Fame didn't even exist it started a
few years after that and they put red
barber and Mel Allen and as the very
first the two of them together I think
in 1978 so the award didn't even exist
but even after it came into existence I
never thought about
about this and in fact this year was the
first time I was eligible what you said
at the start is a very nice thing and
some people have said it to me over this
past several months these past several
months I thought you already in or why
did it take so long this was actually
the first year that I was eligible
because they changed the rules around
but what eligible
I mean I'm what it like what was so what
are the rules well they were up until
last year they were that you had to have
been the voice of a team for 10
consecutive years or the voice of
network baseball for 10 consecutive
years and I was on NBC from the early
80s till 1989 so that fell just short
then again from the mid 90s to 2000 that
NB C lost baseball again and then
eventually they modernized it and they
changed it to where there are now three
categories so it'll be on a three year
cycle one category is national voices so
people like me
Joe Buck Al Michaels and others were on
the ballot this year then next year
local voices which makes sense because
what Tom Hamilton does with the
Cleveland Indians or what John Miller
who's already in now does for the Giants
that's a different thing
then what Matt vasgersian is doing now
on ESPN or whatever the case may be and
then the third category is pioneers
people that they may have overlooked
almost all of whom are gone now guys who
did their primary broadcasting in the
40s 50s and 60s I thought they just
lowered the requirement you have to have
it at least 28 Emmys they did qualified
goodness gracious
and so it's been a while since I have
been to that incredible museum there in
Cooperstown Bob so is there a wall for
this because there's no plaque right
well with an NBC logo on your cap there
correct well no actually yes there is an
area hmm that's called Mike men and
scribes and it's really cool it has like
old-style cathedral radios and old-style
microphones
and you can push a button and hear
Graham McNamee call the World Series or
Vin Scully called Koufax's perfect game
or a Jack buck call or a Lindsey Nelson
call and then there are plaques that are
smaller than the ones that are in the
shrine where the players are recognized
but there are plaques that go
chronologically according to what year
you were inducted but whoever is the
present person that person stays up
there for a year so Bill King who was
inducted posthumously terrific all-round
broadcasted the Warriors and basketball
the Raiders and football and also did
the Oakland A's in baseball he was
inducted posthumously a year ago so his
picture somewhat larger than everybody
else with a scroll beneath that listing
his achievements and whatever qualities
might have led people to to vote him in
that stays up for a year and so that's
where I am as of Saturday and then a
year from Saturday I go back into the
into the list and and I become I become
a tiny plaque maybe maybe twice the size
of a baseball a mere mic man that's what
I'm like man but you know what else is
also cool right next to that is baseball
at the movies so it's an old-style sort
of movie marquee like you're going to
the Bijou Picture Show and it'll say now
showing the natural and there'll be the
movie poster of Robert Redford with with
Glenn Close or now showing Bull Durham
and you'll see Kevin Costner with Susan
Sarandon now showing eight men out now
showing billy crystal's 61 and they have
the whole roll call and there have been
more than 150 movies made not all of
them great but many of them terrific
more than a hundred and fifty movies
made that had baseball as the central
theme and they're all recognized in some
way or another and it's just very cool
Bob Costas Mike man Ford C Frick Award
winner here on the Rich Eisen show so
let's talk about the here and now Bob
why like
on the horn it seems Bryce Harper's not
going anywhere but the fact that it was
even considered to send him somewhere
that mike rizzo the general manager of
the Nationals was on a listening tour of
any sort is just remarkable I'm
wondering why do you think that happened
well two reasons one they may figure
that they cannot meet whatever the
ultimate price is going to be so they
had to consider the possibility of
getting something in return
- he's not having a good season by his
standards
not even close and three the Nats are
kind of on the bubble
are they buyers are they sellers are
they in it are they out of it and the
truth is well the Phillies and the
Braves have been pleasant surprises it's
not like they're so strong that they
can't be caught and it's very possible
that the Nats could reel off 16 out of
20 and be right back there so Rizzo was
in a position where what to do wasn't
100% clear and something that I haven't
heard discuss that much but I think is
certainly a possibility is since Harper
is so young just in his mid-twenties
coming up for free agency so early
because he started his career as a
teenager he could sign a one-year deal
with the Nats that would be mutually
beneficial and then have a more Bryce
Harper type year and go off and sign his
10-year four hundred million dollar
contract with somebody and that somebody
is probably not the Nats but he gets the
springboard of a better season which
would further increase his value and the
Nats get to keep him for one more year
plus there's still time left in this
season for them to make a move it just
seems something off with him and the
Nats I don't know if it's because he's
never really had any any you know a
consistent management with five managers
that are have gone to these been through
or I don't know it just seems there's
something off and it just doesn't work
there bob is that fair to say yeah that
may be true that may be true he won an
MVP I
think he was the Rookie of the Year he
also won an MVP terrific but it just
seems I don't get it it just ya know I
get what you're what you're saying it
just doesn't seem like it's a perfect
fit and maybe in the long run
both he and management will decide that
and when you talk about different
managers how good does Dusty Baker look
right now and that's not a knock on Dave
Martinez but dusty had some big
disappointments in San Francisco
yeah in San Francisco in Chicago in
Cincinnati and in DC in the postseason
but when you look at his overall
managerial record where did Dusty Baker
go where he did poorly the answer to
that is nowhere right alright Bob Costas
here in the Rich Eisen show I can't
believe there's no rule that you can't
acquire a player is under suspension for
domestic violence Bob I mean that that
Roberto Osuna acquisition by the Astros
he just puts puts folks like Verlander
and in a very difficult position since
he's been very outspoken about players
certainly in the organization the
prospect who got popped for domestic
violence on and was seen to have been
beating up a woman on tape he was very
vocal about that kid shouldn't be in
baseball anymore now now they're the the
Astros are just gonna take us closer and
throw him in a in the locker room with a
suspension ah shouldn't there be a rule
that that's not allowed and the question
is still in effect right so but and and
if you are suspended I think now here's
where the rule may differ if you are for
example Robinson Cano if the Mariners
make the postseason is not eligible for
the postseason right that's a good rule
if you're suspended during a season for
PE D use even if you serve the
suspension you can't play in the
postseason and you're not eligible for
all-star honors or whatever it may be
that makes sense and they should extend
that to other significant offenses duis
domestic abuse I think I may
sense right and I say just I hope they
do that I hope that yeah I don't think
obviously they won't be able to do it
retroactively Lee but it right it just
puts people in a very difficult spot
hey Bob I just wanted to get you on and
say congrats to you into the microphone
and say that to you have I started hit
you with a text I was kind of sheepish
sheepish about it because I I knew it
was probably Lots going on and you're in
your life but I'm so thrilled to see you
get that honor in in Cooperstown thanks
rich I really appreciate it I'll see you
soon you bet you bet that's Bob Costas
of MLB network NBC Sports the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience